[موسيقى]
لم تكن هذه الحديقه مجرده يستمتع بجمالها
الزائرون حيث تم تحويلها لقصه يعيش
تفاصيلها الزوار في الفصل الثاني منذ
افتتاحها ضمن مناطق موسم الرياضه
الحديقه المتجدده بالكامل دون تكرار
الموسم الماضي للمطاعم العالميه والمقاهي
والمحلات السعوديه
[موسيقى]
انت تخ
اف علي فكره الفصل الثاني
في قصه جديده فكره جديده
تتبع ذا جروفس الفصل الاول بس لها تكمله
والتكمله هذه لازم يكون احداثها جديده
افكار جديده
المطاعم اللي موجوده جديده
في تغيير شامل
رغبه الزائرين بالمشي في مختلفه الرجاء
الهمت مصمميها بان تكون ذا جروب سهاب
المنطقه التي يستريح بها الزوار
والاستمتاع بالشاي والقهوه السريعه
يقاتل قوه عندنا انه الطبيعه الاجواء
الشتاء في مو كل واحد
يروح مطعم
فقررنا انه المنطقه اللي فيها الاشجار
ونغير البوتات اللي بمنطقه اللي كانت فاشل
الى قهاوي وفي سناب
يعني نحن بنعطي تجربه يعني قبل تجربه من
جهتين
عامله ايه
[موسيقى]
الاجواء والاستثنائيه امتعت رواده ذا
جروفس بالعروض الموسيقيه ويعيش تجربه
السفر للقطب الثلجي وغيرها الكثير من
الزوايا المفاجئه والجاذبه للزوار من
الرياض شهد متروك العربيه